hey guys dr. Berg here in this short
video we're going to talk about why
people eliminate less by eating more
fiber you've heard it people say you
need to eat more fiber and it's going to
help you eliminate but a lot of times it
doesn't work so let's talk about why
that is so this whole idea of fiber
creating bulk absorbing water to make
you eliminate more you realize that the
people with chronic constipation consume
the same amount of fiber as people who
don't have constipation yeah so that's
interesting people with chronic
constipation get more constipated when
they add more fiber there's a there's
also a small amount of clients that I
have where I put them on seven to ten
cups of vegetables and they get
completely constipated so there are
certain people that just don't have the
microbes to digest all that fiber well
first thing you need to know is that you
want to consume your fiber from
vegetables and possibly even fruit if
you're not trying to lose weight okay
now let's say you're really constipated
and you do have a weight problem and
you've tried everything well I'm okay
with you doing fruit because there are
certain types of fibers in the fruit
that do create elimination like prunes
for example so I have no problem with
that
because it's much more important to
eliminate than to be constipated
especially if you're trying to lose
weight okay but here's the thing if you
consume all your fiber from fruit and by
the way the recommended amount of fiber
that even the USDA is recommending is 35
grams of fiber per day if you do that
from fruit that's 143 grams of sugar
that's 10 teaspoons of sugar every
single day well that's actually probably
even better than the average American
who consumes 31 teaspoons of sugar every
single day but still that's way too much
sugar so you don't want to do all route
you want to do mainly vegetable in fact
try not to do any fruit if you don't
have to but vegetable is the best fiber
now I consume at least probably 10 to 15
cups of vegetables a day but I've been
doing it for a long time so my system
can process these fibers so you might
want to start off small and gradually
increase but if you below
especially kale then you better back off
and try something else because it's way
more important to not bloat then to
consume kale okay and the other thing is
that if you're drinking a lot of water
if you're drinking too much water which
by the way will dehydrate your stool and
the reason for that is that plain water
will flush out sometimes potassium and
other electrolytes that you need to
actually hydrate the colon so I have
people that are constipated and they had
really Drive stool and they're drinking
like a gallon of water a day so we cut
that back put some electrolytes in and
bam they're actually eliminating one of
the most important minerals for called
peristalsis which is the pumping action
of the colon is potassium so potassium
is important especially if you want to
get it from a less n type of electrolyte
powder that will also help you as well
because that will also stimulate part of
the nervous system that helps release
this waste materials called the
parasympathetic nervous system and that
actually is kind of the opposite of the
sympathetic or the flooded fight and
that's why it you have to be really
stress free and relaxed to eliminate
when you're stressed out there's a
reflex that just turns off the digestive
system so anyway I want to make a point
in fiber so go ahead and apply this
information and I will see you in the
next video